ten years in the making
the reign of Thanos is finally upon us
packed with comic references callbacks
to prior films and little Easter eggs
that only the most hardcore of fans will
get infinity war delivers on a lot of
levels even after several moons of the
movie there are still small tidbits that
I notice and throughout this video I'll
be discussing the most minor of details
from the incredible film there will of
course be heavy spoilers here and I
definitely recommend that you check out
all of the MCU movies before watching
this video in case something is
inadvertently spoiled for you with that
out the way I'm definition and this is
my top eight amazing details that you
missed in Infinity Ward Civil War call
back the sokovia record scene from Civil
War is one of the standout sequences of
the film but did you know that it also
alludes to other elements in infinity
war during the briefing with general
Ross we see The Avengers set around a
table listening to why their actions of
thus far have led to more destruction
this of course plays into how Thanos has
secretly manipulated them but their
positioning during the briefing is what
is most interesting all of those that on
the left survive the snap whilst those
set on the right don't Tony is also
sitting far away from his allies just
like how he is in the finale of the film
when he is left stranded far away from
them on Titan the story of Genesis
throughout infinity war Danis denies
that he wishes to become a god even when
questioned by Loki the antagonist shuts
down the idea that he seeks to become an
omnipotent being however there are
several similarities to Stannis his
destruction of the universe and the
Christian God's creation of it
Donner seeks to find six Infinity stones
which could be seen as a metaphor for
the six days that God took to create the
universe there's also the huge glaring
similarity that on the seventh day God
rested much in the same way that Danis
did after completing his six tasks
Proxima midnight Proxima midnight is
played by Carrie [ __ ] who starred in the
leftovers which ironically is about a
large portion of the world's population
mysteriously disappearing from her which
is of course what happens at the end of
infinity war dr. strange knew there was
only one way to remove the
dr. strange famously others this was the
only way after he and his allies failed
to remove the Infinity Gauntlet from
Dennis's hand knowing that there was
only one way to get it off
strange allows that us to win so that he
will in fact remove it himself when he
believes his mission is completed
hypothetically this will allow the
Avengers down the line to achieve their
mission of taking the Gorka back and
with Thanos no longer wearing it the
goal of attaining it becomes infinitely
more easier alien Queen in order to take
out ebony more Peter refers to the
classic sci-fi horror movie aliens in
that film we see the character Ripley
blow the alien queen out of an airlock
and ebony more is killed much in the
same way even to the point that we get
eerily similar shot of him flying
through space dead in the exact same
position as the alien Queen was in the
James Cameron classic rocket is the
captain now during their first meeting
rocket puts himself as the captain of
the guardians to thought well it's at
the time this is done as a joke upon the
film's climax it actually comes true
Gamora is killed early on and the rest
of the guardians are during the snap
which automatically makes rocket the
captain
by default dannis dies immediately after
the snap we see thermos rejoined Gamora
and what appears to be the afterlife she
asked why it costs to which he replies
everything in my opinion this is true on
every level even to the point that the
character himself was killed during the
snap this allowed him to visit the
recently dead character Gamora in the
afterlife and speak with her
however the soul stone which was still
in his possession brought him back to
life and this also explains how he was
able to recover from the huge axe wound
that he received at the hands of thought
the extra gauntlet when thought creates
Stormbreaker we see that there's a mold
for the Infinity Gauntlet with the one
that I saw having clearly been destroyed
by the snap this mold could provide the
Avengers with the gall
our own that they could use to wield the
stones this is purely speculation at the
moment but it seems like another highly
plausible way for the survivors to
avenge the fall infinity Wars obviously
filled to the brim with Matic signifiers
Easter eggs and more so if you think
that there's any that I missed or you
think there's some that should have made
the list please comment below and let me
know I'd love to hear your thoughts and
if you'd like to see more of my
discussions please check out my ant-man
and the wasp post-credit scene theory as
well as my Odin Infinity Gauntlet fan
theory video both of which will be
linked at the end of this one if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and subscribe to my channel as I create
content like this weekly and they'll
definitely be something on the channel
that you love if you're a fan of film
again thanks very much for taking the
time to watch this and I'll see you next
time take care peace
you